qu'est ce qui compte pour toi
quand as tu été le plus heureux
montrent un business à partir de cette
sensation
quelle mouche vous viennent à l'esprit
quand je vous dis espace de travail quoi
bureau
meubles moche et au mauvais éclairage
moore
tout à fait d'accord
l'avenir il est en pleine métamorphose
on vend une expérience
il faut qu'on trouve un nom wii ou et
les fouilles dream we work
qui gagne ses combats c'est
l'intelligence c'est le far
vous met pas assez fou je peux l'être je
peux l'être
[Rires]
escada mais sérieux je serai pas avec
l'uci ne l'était pas la femme elle
travaille la balle l'aide à manifester
des jours on est parti pour perdre plus
de 400 millions de dollars certains j'ai
pas tip top
je me sens à peu près c'est à toi de
leur montrer hockey très quoi tu étais
super dans là
et tu t'inquiètes tilt sur place
êtes vous une franc tireuse ou muse je
suis une nuise parlez-moi de vos
ambitions toi avec gilles on fit dans
vanity fair vanity fair n'est pas pour
les mus
par ce que je veux changer ma réponse
je voulais que vous rencontriez le
légendaire adam newman ainsi que sa
femme j'essuie sa chef de marque au nom
des espaces de bureaux et on se comporte
comme si on changeait le monde ils vont
vous lâchez vous allez faire couler le
navire
sur un point 9 milliards de pertes
rien n'est plus important et nous j'ai
la responsabilité de voir plus grand je
suis la poule aux oeufs d'or si vous
arrivez à vous en rendre compte qu'ils
n'auraient rien pu faire sans moi
on part en guerre
si on fait ça tous les deux on va tout
changer on va tout changer
[Musique]